This is Jocko podcast number one 50 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
And who are the young men we are asking to go into action against such solid
odds
you've met them,
you know
they are the best we have,
but they are not McNamara's sons or Bundys.
I doubt they are yours.
And they know,
they know they are at the end of the pipeline
that no one cares.
They know.
And that right there is an anonymous quote from a general in Vietnam,
two correspondent,
a war correspondent named Arthur Hailey,
who is actually himself a decorated tank commander in World War II who enlisted
in the army.
And there's a key word I said there.
You know,
a volunteer who voluntarily enlisted in the army in World War II and in Vietnam
and the Vietnam War.
You hear a lot about the draftees in Vietnam.
And in fact,
25% of the forces that fought in Vietnam were draftees.
And draftees accounted for 30% of the deaths in Vietnam.
Now on this podcast,
we've heard from a bunch of those volunteers,
a bunch of those career soldiers,
marines that fought in Vietnam.
But tonight we're honored to have as someone on the podcast
that was not necessarily a v a volunteer that was not necessarily looking to be
in the military for a career,
but who nonetheless a stepped up and did his job for our country.
And once he served his time,
he came home and lived his life and he had a son and his son is also joined us
on the podcast.
And his son took a different route.
He was guided by his dad,
but he was guided not to war but to the water.
So we have tonight,
Dave Hall,
Vietnam veteran tanker,
who's also the father of Josh Hall,
who's a surfer,
a craftsmen,
a surfboard,
and an entrepreneur.
And I think we're looking forward to this at least I am so welcome to the show,
both of you.
Thanks for coming on,
Josh.
Dave,
awesome to have you.
Yeah,
thanks for coming out here from Hawaii.
I know,
you know,
most people don't want to leave Hawaii.
No one new there.
But I'm glad we were able to drag out here.
No,
it was a burden on me.
Yeah,
I love to see my son.
Awesome.
Awesome Josh.
Thanks for coming on.
Thank you John.
I know we've been seeing each other in the water for awhile and at contests and
whatnot,
so it's good we linked up and,
and have this opportunity to come on and talk about it.
Talk about some of my favorite things,
Warren and surfing.
So Dave,
we've got to start with you and you know,
we always kind of try and take it back to the beginning and just kind of what
your background was and you know where you came from.
I know what you were born in,
born in Boston,
Massachusetts.
And what'd Your Dad do?
My Dad was a,
my dad did many things.
A World War Two.
He is a pilot and a [inaudible] 17 over in England.
And
so that's one that just slipped under the radar because your dad was a B 17
pilot in World War II.
Yeah.
Dang.
And be 20 fours and,
uh,
he always wanted to be a fighter pilot and he tried to go to the Pacific
minutiae.
That never happened.
So anyway,
he's married my mom.
Um,
and then,
uh,
okay.
We ended up living in Boston for awhile.
I mean we travel around the country cause he was still in the service and an air
force,
uh,
living in Texas and lived in Colorado.
Lived in [inaudible].
Was He,
was he a career army guy?
Army Air Force Guy,
yes.
For a little while.
Okay.
I don't know exactly when he got out,
when he did get out.
Um,
he started flying for United Airlines.
Okay.
And I know in the 50s and stuff he went to,
I don't think he went to Korea.
I,
I'm lost right now.
Okay.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
he,
he uh,
he did a multitude of things.
He was a teacher,
a lawyer,
a farmer,
a farm in Nebraska.
He was born in Nebraska,
had we had a big ranch back there.
And um,
he taught school in Nebraska and then,
uh,
okay.
We had been living in Santa Ana till I was nine years old.
I went to visit,
uh,
my grandfather in Nebraska and then that summer,
at the end of the summer,
my folks ended up coming out with all the kids and the,
the whole house and he decided not to fly for United Airlines anymore and become
a farmer again.
So yeah,
I was kind of different.
So anyways,
that's,
yeah,
like I said,
I lived in a lot of states and stuff because during this,
because of the service,
but a Nebraska was kind of like my favorite place.
I know from there
now.
Did you work on the farm?
Every kid grows up on a farm is like slave labor.
Exactly.
Oh absolutely.
Yeah.
10 hours
field plowing.
Uh,
you know,
we had a cow,
we had to milk every day,
you know,
we called her six o'clock,
six o'clock in the morning,
six o'clock at night,
and a few other cattle and we had bigs and I raised 300 chicken,
you know,
and of course,
I mean,
you know,
I had my brother and sisters and stuff were there too.
They all helped out.
And this is when you're what,
like 10,
11,
12,
11?
Yeah,
I'm going to back there at Cannes and I was back there for like 43 summers,
you know,
so I was 12,
I think we ended up moving back to Connecticut.
And then how long were you out there for?
A year in Connecticut.
And then I,
then my dad,
um,
he bought a business here in San Diego and hall and hall personnel and uh,
so we moved back out here and he found a place and we lived out in Spring Valley
and um,
he worked downtown,
has an office down there.
So yeah,
it was kinda different.
That's the thing.
You spend your,
your high school years here in San Diego?
I started
great in San Diego,
went to Mt.
Miguel in high school and um,
then I graduated and went to,
I was going to college for Awhile and then,
uh,
that's drafted.
Did you,
did you start surfing in high school?
Actually,
when we lived in Santa Ana and said I didn't surf,
we,
we had mats,
you know,
me and mad maps up there,
my mom.
Oh yeah.
So,
and I was young then and we'd always go down to a on take me every day,
you know,
down me and the kids and,
and uh,
to Laguna beach down there,
China coat down there and uh,
yeah,
broke my ear drum down there as a matter of fact.
Yeah.
But anyways,
yeah.
Uh,
and then I started,
I started surfing,
you know,
10th grade,
ninth grade and stuff.
But uh,
yeah,
we,
uh,
when we first came out here and stuff,
I'd love to,
I thought we were going to move to the beach.
We stayed at the San Diego Motel right down there on,
uh,
it's across from in and out.
And we stayed there until my dad found a house to live.
Man,
you know,
so I,
I go to the beach then,
you know,
walk to the beat.
Oh yeah.
It was fun.
That's what everyone thinks.
Well,
people that don't live in California,
think all of California is like Bay Watch.
That's the,
or realize that there's,
you know,
massive,
I mean,
obviously there's massive swaths of land,
but agriculture is huge.
You know,
you'd go up the,
you just drive by farm after farm,
after farm,
after farm.
So much in California is farming and,
but people think everything in California is just,
they watch,
it's not,
can come close sometimes.
But then you,
when you went to high school here and you,
you did surf,
but you weren't,
you weren't able to get to the water that much?
Quite a bit.
Actually.
I had a,
my dad bought me a 53 Chevy [inaudible] 54 Chevy two door and stuff.
So I ripped out the backseat,
so I get my boards in there.
And um,
then I got my sister's car.
If he had a,
a station wagon and it was a 57 Ford two door deluxe,
you know,
it was,
the whole thing that was a surf wagon.
Oh yeah.
I know.
So me and the boys,
no.
So I was wrong.
Do you actually got to the water a lot?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
quite a bit.
You,
you wrestled
in high school?
Yeah,
a little bit of a wrestling.
Uh,
I was mostly on the,
uh,
that was on the swim team.
I dove and I swam and,
um,
my fault,
you know,
somebody said,
nick,
can anybody do the butterfly and go,
yeah,
I can.
I know in early.
So you,
you're the butterfly guy.
And then,
so during this time period,
were you paying attention,
I mean,
obviously your dad was in the,
was,
you know,
out of the military,
but you had that connection to the military.
Were you paying attention in those years?
Because now we're talking,
this is like the mid sixties.
Are you paying attention to what's happening in Vietnam?
You're just,
you're focused on,
yeah.
Right.
I know it was a kid,
but,
um,
not that I can really recall.
It wasn't really on my radar.
Yeah,
it,
and then you graduate and your figure you're going to go to college for a bit.
Yeah,
junior college.
What year did you graduate high school?
66.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
So Vietnam was still relatively wasn't,
yeah,
I mean they started with the bow.
The,
I drank valley was in 1965 and that was kind of like the big first spike in
activity.
Not,
I don't want to say that,
but it was definitely a highlight and started hitting the news more.
And that was in 65 so you graduated in [inaudible] 66 yeah.
I mean there was talk draft and the draft and stuff like that,
but it wasn't like,
you know,
like I said it wasn't,
I didn't really pay attention to it.
Yeah.
Surfing can distract you from all kinds of the world's problems,
which is a good thing.
So then,
so then you role to a Grossmont college,
you're there.
Yeah.
And now are you,
are you starting to become more aware of the draft at this point?
No.
No,
cause I,
I snow skied a lot so I know there's a lot of activity and I belonged to the ski
club there at Grossmont and also we'd go to squaw valley heavenly and,
and,
and ski a lot.
So no,
I still didn't really think about it.
I didn't think about it until I saw my mom pulled a little envelope up,
you know.
And she said,
hey,
you got something from the government and what was your reaction to that?
I can't go to Mozza lawn.
Yeah.
So I mean it was,
it hit you that it was that unexpected for you when you got that,
when you got your draft notice.
Yeah.
Did you know any other guys that had been drafted?
Oh yeah.
The class before me and stuff.
No,
I don't like Jim Thompson,
a great guy.
Um,
he just 25th infantry over there and stuff.
They came back with all the war stories.
So I take that back.
I was aware of it because all these guys are coming back and talking about it,
but I never thought I know me.
I didn't worry about gone.
So,
yeah.
So then when you got it,
what was your reaction when you got it?
Well,
I'm going to go,
I guess.
Yeah,
it was either that,
you know,
are run and hide and I thought,
well,
you know,
if we'd make it a muzzle on it,
it's not a bad place to be.
I know if I can survive there.
So,
and then I said,
well,
no,
I got to do it.
Yeah,
it was a little bit scary,
but you know,
I,
I was looking forward to things,
you know,
I mean,
I didn't look forward to going over there,
but I mean,
it's kind of.